we've all missed so much in our lives
over the last 12 months but maybe
holidays are towards the top of that
list the excitement of
planning booking and then travelling is
something that we all look forward to in
our year
so we're delighted that on monday of
next week we'll be putting on sale
holidays sailing in the uk coastal
waters
of the uk on our flagship britannia
and our newest ship iona so giving
people the opportunity to break the norm
and get away and have that ultimate
staycation on our ships with all the
incredible food
and entertainment that's to offer um
but i suspect that people will be
needing to show
some some of some form of immunity
uh to covert 19 before they're allowed
to get on board well one of the things i
think we can be
very proud of as a nation is our
vaccination program
and current estimates show that a huge
number of people will be vaccinated by
this summer
and our first sailing is in actual fact
the 27th of june
so we're anticipating a very large
audience
being able to book onto our holidays but
as you're right
we are asking our guests to prove that
they've had
uh they are vaccinated they've had their
second dose
and then we will welcome them on board
to give them an incredible holiday
um from what you're saying then it and
we always
we've long known of course that there is
a certain age to which the
those who head regularly on cruises
tends to skew i mean
isn't it the case that you know these
cruises these ultimate escapes that are
going to be taking place well
look you're going to have to be over a
certain age to enjoy them well
cruise holidays are getting younger and
younger by the year as more people
understand the incredible value and
choice that a cruise holiday can
provide we are anticipating by the
middle of the summer of this year that
in actual fact a large proportion of the
population
and relatively young members of the
population will be fully vaccinated and
therefore will be free to come and enjoy
our holiness with us
well that's great so but just in terms
of moving forward and of course piano
has
you know penal cruises a slightly
different beast to the kind of the
the more straightforward ferry aspect of
the job
i mean what is your general feeling
about when
the cruise industry will be back in the
position
to be doing that the longer haul trips
the the high profile trips the
the more expensive trips that you
provide so we
very much see the return to service in a
number of stages
the first stage being this uk offering
staycations uh for this summer and then
as we move through to the late part of
the summer and into the autumn i think
we'll move back to what
our guests are more familiar with
international cruising
so i think there's something to look
forward to both in the short and the
medium term
for people to look into book holidays
this year